the Joe Rogan experience it's difficult
to procure hmm right it's difficult to
get someone who's really attractive to
like you yeah right I mean there's a
reason why you and I are funny Yeah
right
it's be honest like why are why are most
men why do they have a sense of humor
they have a sense of humor because girls
like that mmm that's a big it's a big
one
like you can kind of jump through a lot
of Hoops do you skip a lot of steps if
you're funny yeah if you're a guy and
you're funny cuz you have to be smart to
be funny see girls like oh he knows how
to be funny yeah you know and if they're
not funny but they then you're funny you
can make them laugh they're like yes
bring this [ __ ] comedian with me
everywhere right and I always have my
own little show yeah and when she likes
you because of that you're like oh she
likes me because I'm funny
that'll get funnier yeah I'll work at
this yeah I'll be good at this too when
I was in sixth grade me and John your
Zak used to do comedy routines for the
girls at lunch we had whole [ __ ]
routines like you know like Marx
Brothers stuff and Muppet Show [ __ ] like
whatever worked we were up there
tap-dancing for those girls
Vicki Batman and reg they loved it so
funny and I remember that feeling back
then because I was the skinny little kid
with red hair and freckles no chicks
took they just cared about the guys that
were good at sports and all sudden like
I'm getting laughs and and I just
remember feeling like this is what I
want to do this is this is what I need
to do yeah you found like you yeah yeah
so there's that right it's like when
guys see a car like a brand-new Mercedes
in a commercial and there's a girl with
long legs and high heels and she's
leaning against the car like oh my god
is that girl come in the car if I get
the car while get her yeah I need to get
her it's hard to get one of those you
get a girl with long legs and high heels
and beautiful lips and she's looking at
you like she loves you that's so
difficult to find it's so difficult to
get most of the time those girls they
look up they walk right by you look you
don't even exist look at that if I get
that watch that watch there's a girl
staring at that watch she loves that
watch oh gotta get that watch yeah and
that's like what's used to sell most
things like how many things in America
in particular are sold by attractive
yeah attractive women in ads attractive
women like that we associate if you get
this Lamborghini attractive women will
be more drawn to you because it's
difficult to get a Lamborghini right
this guy can get a Lamborghini that
means he's got 300,000 dollars to throw
on a stupid car that's probably gonna
break down yeah jon hamm doing those car
ads women [ __ ] they want to get in
that car with John I am Matthew
McConaughey it him look at that house he
lives in I can't be in that house I just
need to if I meet him he'll love me I
would put a couch over there though mmm
shrubs inside the house fix it kind of a
modern painting it just needs a woman's
touch
then he has sex within he's like I got
to go oh but I thought but it's your
house we're forever yeah oh the ultimate
biological trick if they forever dead
that's what's gonna be really weird like
if you look at aliens right one that
what's the the iconic alien they have
the big heads they have these little boy
like bodies long fingers no dicks yeah
there's nothing there all right cuz
that's probably what happens in the
future
yeah in the future we all figure out
listen we are being tricked left and
right by our dicks and our vaginas and
our sex hormones are talking us into
nonsense well we could just be
enlightened yeah and we could travel the
galaxy together but we've got to get
past all this sex stuff this biological
sex stuff and you can you could have an
orgasm in your own brain yeah with your
list new phone iPhone 72 yeah and just
press the button and they get that out
of your system good now we don't need
sex anymore
yeah and we don't need our mouths either
we need to talk with our brains just
yeah big giant head what kind of slit
for a mouth mm-hmm it's like remember
that Woody Allen movie sleepers and they
have the orgasmatron oh and you just
pass it around and then you have an
orgasm and then you move on that was it
I mean you think about how much work is
involved in trying to get an orgasm like
how much energy people spend and then
the seduction right you meet someone at
a bar can I buy you a drink okay let me
to light that cigarette can't do that
anymore but that was a thing right yeah
like light the girl
cigarette mm-hmm buy a drink oh he's so
charming
Oh Oh thinking maybe dance is a mating
dance let's dance
why should we shake my hips I'm gonna
dance a guy who doesn't know how to
dance probably sucks in bed yeah that
guy [ __ ] dance him dance
maybe it's time to breed I'm gonna breed
with a conqueror a man who could dance
and knows how to light a cigarette he
could kill somebody from me he's big
he's big he knows how to think he knows
that we got to get out of here
troubles brewing oh he's a protector Oh
wanna get in his nice car you can drive
fast boom boom whoa Wow he lives in the
top of the hill whoo he's got a good
spot we can see the enemies coming a
long way yeah so weird people I mean
that's our business is like getting
people to like us right there's a big
part of what our business is our
business is like saying funny [ __ ] so
people like us yeah and other people do
different things like some girls they
just work on their squats you know just
go to the gym a lot so that people like
them more elastics out more get more
attention all right no some people are
just funny some people they acquire
things some people acquire power respect
influence yeah watch this nature special
on the what are those animals that hang
upside down in Australia bats no they're
like furry they're furry and cute
Wallabies know every balance around for
you what they're called but I'm bats no
they got they've got him I got him here
too I think but anyway this [ __ ]
is on one side of the river and he can
hear a mating call from the other side
of the river and he's slow as [ __ ] sloth
sloth I thought so this slot here is the
female sloth and he [ __ ] me and I
don't know where they get these cameras
from but they watch this guy go down the
tree across a limb into the water can't
swim for [ __ ] there's [ __ ] Rapids he
makes
Oh Oh cause he could hear that yeah gets
across climbs on it takes like two days
and then he finds this up his father
then he climbs on top of her a couple
shakes of the head Oh who's this [ __ ]
but now he can think I can thank you
know Jesus she wants to eat my fruit
it's my fruit [ __ ]
[Applause]